la question qui nous occupe à cette
heure est une question
démocratique majeure après l'échec de
cette réforme à l'Assemblée nationale
une majorité du Sénat va-t-elle décider
de permettre le coup de force qui a été
qui est tenté par le gouvernement contre
les deux plus belles années de rotin des
Français un coup de force contre
l'immense majorité du pays un coup de
force contre tous les syndicats un coup
de force contre l'avenir du régime de
retraite par répartition nous débattons
ici depuis le 2 mars ça a été dit tout à
l'heure par Madame la rapporteur depuis
6 jours les Français nous écoutent les
Français nous suivent ils ont entendu
tous les arguments les vôtres les nôtres
ceux du rapporteur ceux du gouvernement
ils ont manifesté aujourd'hui en
connaissance de cause
et le pays a répondu clairement que pour
lui c'était non et il a dit non dans
toutes les villes de France dans tous
les départements dans toutes nos régions
tous nos électeurs étaient dans la rue
quand je dis tous nos électeurs c'est
les nôtres c'est les vôtres aussi tout
c'était dans la rue pour dire NON de
toute catégories sociales et j'attire
votre attention parce que c'est un fait
majeur de la journée d'aujourd'hui
l'entrée en lice massif de la jeunesse
de la jeunesse dans les manifestations
et cela va s'amplifier
nous avons vérifié pendant cette
discussion ce que les syndicats ont
vérifié pendant trois mois en essayant
de négocier avec le gouvernement le
gouvernement et la droite ne veulent
rien négocier vous êtes obsédé par une
seule idée les 64 ans à part ça rien ne
vous intéresse aucune piste alternative
de trouve grâce à vos yeux et bien je le
répète face au pays qui est unanimement
mobilisé c'est un coup de force ne
donnez pas la main à ce coup de force
sénateur et sénatrice du Sénat nous
n'avons pas à le faire
[Musique]